and i have i have a special guest with
me kfa karen how are you
i'm great thanks for having me nice to
see you yes it is so good to have you
here everyone everyone knows that you
are the co-host of the wednesday edition
of legal af how many of you guys have
been doing the episode how many episodes
have you guys done for this wednesday
it's been it's been several weeks hasn't
it yeah it has i think i think we're up
to maybe 13 or 14 i i'm not exactly sure
but around that number so we're getting
there that's fantastic that's fantastic
so everyone out there uh no the midas
mighty is a
is part of our fan base too you know you
know we we come to you from the the
midas touch facebook page and we are a
proud partners of mind as touch so we
have a lot of the midas mighty so they
know exactly who karen is and and if you
don't catch the wednesday edition you
can go to the mind as touch facebook
page and watch
live and live chat with
pope hoc because we've had pope on the
show and karen
during
during the show live you can you can
chat with him there on the youtube page
or you can catch it out on
any of the uh the podcast directories
out there so catch the special wednesday
edition but karen you have you have a
very special resume
um you used to work in a certain office
it may or may not be the manhattan da's
office is that correct
that is correct yes but you did not work
for the current manhattan d.a is that is
that correct also that is correct i
worked for the two prior manhattan da's
i started under robert morgenthau
and i worked for him for about 15 years
then i left and i went to work for mayor
mike bloomberg of new york city for a
few years and then when when cyrus vance
jr was elected district attorney i began
working for him in 2010 and i stayed
almost till the end of his
administration
which was uh he served three terms so 12
years
and he decided not to run again and and
i was his chief assistant da which is
the number two so i basically helped run
the whole office and um i knew when he
wasn't going to run that
the new da whoever it would be would
want their own new chief assistant so i
had to decide do i want to run for d.a
or do i want to
or i have to leave and find a new job
and i made this decision so here i am
and yes that's where i worked well we
are very happy i mean i
there i i have mixed feelings i wish you
were in charge over there at the da's
office right now because we have a
little we have a little of a mixed bag
over there um and there's probably
things that you cannot talk about
because there's probably some things
that you do know that we can't reveal
here on the show
but i do want to ask you about
how the manhattan da's work because a
lot of people don't know like how many
terms can you serve how long the term is
because the question is a lot of times
it's like well this brag guy right he
won he won the election and he's decided
at this point there's question rather
he's going to prosecute we've seen
pomerantz uh a special investigator with
the d.a had left
uh the the resignation letter uh had
released it was obvious why everyone
thought they knew why he had left and
and the resignation letter lays it out
there so how long is a term for the d.a
how does that work
so the d.a so new york city is comprised
of five boroughs manhattan brooklyn the
bronx queens and staten island and each
borough also known as a county has its
own elected district attorney so the
manhattan da's office is exactly that
it's the manhattan district attorney is
the d.a of manhattan and just the island
of manhattan and prosecutes and
investigates crimes
that uh
involve the cri um the island of
manhattan it's a four-year term and
there are no term limits so
robert morgenthau for example was
district attorney for three decades
and you know there haven't been that
many da's and there haven't been that
many manhattan da's uh they've all been
they've all been white men and you know
when you look at the people who are
traditionally prosecuted by the
manhattan da's office and most local
prosecutors it's
it's 9 out of 10 people of color it's
you know unfortunately and i think at
this time and and one of the reasons i
decided not to run was i felt like at
this moment in time it was time for a
person of color and to bring a new
perspective into the district attorney's
office and i was really excited about
album bragg at the time he has an
incredible resume and he has incredible
experience and he also has a really
interesting life story growing up as a
black man in new york city and i felt
like it really is time you know what i
what i was doing all this time was very
much old school not old school it was
progressive to a point and clearly it
was time for a new perspective
but i'm starting to wonder whether he
whether my support for him was uh
you know was was was warranted i mean
there were a couple of good candidates
he was one of the ones i didn't endorse
him necessarily but i was rooting for
him you know i love the office it's i
would say it's probably the best
prosecutor's office in the country it's
always had a great reputation and
really rooting for him to do things
differently and to bring a new
perspective but i have to say he's made
some decisions that are really
disappointing
and i'm hearing from people in the
office they're not happy and people are
leaving in droves
and i'm i'm very concerned so what what
can be done about this because i had
michael popock your your your co-host
on the wednesday edition of legal af i
had him on the show and we asked him a
few questions about um what is what
power does the governor have because
from what i understand and in most
states i think it is this way that the
governor of the state has the power and
the ability to
um basically pull a mulligan if you want
to
refer to it that way with a district
attorney or any attorney or maybe even
assign a special prosecutor so is there
anything that can be done um where we
see the letter from pomerantz and
pomerantz lays it out in very clear
language trump has committed crimes not
like maybe not like possibly
not like uh it could be criminal
activity he's like trump is a criminal
he committed crimes you have to
prosecute him and if you're not i'm
going to leave that's basically what the
letter says so is there anything that
can be done at this point from the
governor anyone else
so there's a couple of things um
the governor could make a referral
to the attorney general's office and the
reason that's important is the attorney
general um who is has a parallel
investigation a civil investigation her
name's uh leticia james she has a
parallel civil investigation that was in
conjunction with the manhattan da's
office into the crimes that the
manhattan da's office was investigating
so it had nothing to do with january 6
for example the manhattan da's office
was investigating
the valuation of various properties
either overvaluing or undervaluing
depending on whether they want to pay
taxes less taxes or they want to be able
to have an appraisal and make more get
more money um on the property so you
know that's really what that
investigation was about is very discreet
and the governor could give
tish james jurisdiction criminal
jurisdiction over that if she wanted and
and she's indicated she's aware of her
of her powers and her authority on on
how she can do that
so that is one possibility another
possibility is um is the feds you know
the us attorney's offices and they all
have
the us attorney's office has criminal
jurisdiction and they could prosecute
this as well you know in my i have a
sort of secret fantasy in my head where
i'm thinking the southern district of
new york which is notorious for being
independent they actually um
tongue-in-cheek call themselves the
sovereign district of new york because
you know they sort of do things um
very innovative and bring cases um in a
way that isn't necessarily
uh
the department of justice is slightly
separate from them you know they do
their own thing and they're respected to
do their own thing and trusted and in my
mind i'm hoping they're they're calling
mark pomerantz up who who resigned who
was the special prosecutor and is a
former federal prosecutor and puts him
in the grand jury i mean the work has
been done you know people are frustrated
with merrick garland because he's taking
they say he's taking too long to
investigate
the um the the crimes surrounding the
insurrection january 6 and and other
trump
and trump administration crimes but
investigations take time and you can't
put pressure especially political
pressure on criminal investigations
because that can actually
infect them and and infuse politics into
into criminal investigation and the
minute you put politics in there people
it loses credibility and and and the the
power to prosecute someone really needs
to be independent and separate it's a
separate branch of government and it
really you have to have faith in
in the judicial system and you know i i
will i have to say trump was the first
time
ever that i think we we sort of started
to lose faith in the department of
justice because he was in infecting
criminal prosecutions with politics and
i i know that
biden and and garland want to bring that
independence and that respect back so
you got to keep politics out of
out of this but but the investigation
that long
several year investigation that the
manhattan da's office was not doing they
did the work they were ready to go into
the grand jury they were ready to bring
indictments so the work is done and and
in my mind i'm wondering whether the
southern district
could call mark pomerantz up and
prosecute the case that he and carrie
dunn and the rest of the team at the
manhattan da's office has put together
all these years and i also think it's it
could be an easier prosecution or at
least an easier indictment because in in
new york state in order to seek an
indictment and you go into the grand
jury you have to put non-hearsay
evidence which means live every every
piece of evidence you put in has to come
from the person giving the evidence so
you could have hundreds of witnesses who
have to come in and testify and tell
what they know and put in their records
and their documents but the feds don't
have that requirement they can put
hearsay into the grand jury so i wonder
and i you know look i'm not a federal
prosecutor i'm not an expert in that but
i'm wondering could they just put mark
pomerantz into the grand jury get an
indictment and then subpoena all of the
records that the manhattan da's office
has and just bring that case
and and that's what i'm hoping is
happening i'm hoping that it's happening
behind the scenes you know i'm i'm the
fact that we don't know about it is okay
and probably a good thing you don't want
leaks coming out of your justice
department or your prosecutor's offices
and so i'm just hoping that that's
what's happening behind the scenes and
we will see a case in short order but
that that's what needs to happen if it's
not you know i i'm glad you segued into
the department of justice um through the
southern district of new york in
southern district of new york because i
believe there's a lot of federal
districts that are probably quietly
investigating a lot of the trump
shenanigans that not only happened
before he came president but uh while he
was president and then after he lost the
election i believe there's probably a
federal um jurisdiction down in georgia
that's interested in some of the fraud
that he committed down there and tried
to try to intimidate election officials
down there i believe that's a federal
crime i'm not sure i'm not a lawyer but
you know or a prosecutor but i i believe
that that possibly could be a federal
crime yeah in that district as well so
because i i am i am at the same level
you are about uh marigoran the
department of justice um
here's the thing
it is very authoritarian which scares
the absolute bejesus out of me
when
left-wing people say merrick garland
should just wave his magic wand and
merrick garland should prosecute anyone
and everyone
within five feet of donald trump right
like that's the that's the feeling that
you get and they're really questioning
the institution not so much merrick
garland which is i think um the slow
walk to authoritarianism
i mean these same people who are now
complaining about merrick garland not
doing enough to be an authoritarian
figure in the department of justice were
complaining about bill barr being an
authoritarian figure in the department
of justice and it really is now i
understand that the country is very
on edge here and has a lot of anxiety
about our democracy
if this stuff continues and people
aren't held accountable not just for
january 6 but the crimes that he
possibly committed and probably
committed with his uh his money washing
machine that is the trump organization
in
in new york but also some of these
uh intimidation tactics that he used in
some of these elections during the big
lie
so
if if you could explain to people
because you've been in the prosecutor's
office why it is so important
for a prosecutor's office like the
manhattan da's or the southern district
of new york or the department of justice
in general
to not say a single peep
about an investigation because if that
invest if certain information gets out
about that investigation it could hurt
it so explain that to us just a little
bit
sure so there's there's
many reasons why you don't want leaks to
get out first of all
putting together an investigation
depends on having witnesses who are
willing to cooperate
and you have to have people you can
subpoena them but at the same time you
want people to be able to come in and
testify
and so if you don't want them to be
intimidated you don't want them to be
afraid you also don't want them to
talk to peop to listen to the news about
um facts
and and suddenly they're going to now
give facts that they heard on the news
that's not the that's not their
their mind their evidence their memory
and that's what it has to be so part of
it is is to preserve the evidence and to
preserve the integrity of the evidence
and so that you make sure you know
sometimes when people in in high profile
uh cases you sometimes like in a murder
case you'll sometimes get some some
people who come in and you know confess
to the crime you know these people have
mental health issues or other problems
and they come and they confess to the
crime and one of the things that um that
law enforcement does is they they test
the person to see do they know facts
about the crime that was never published
in the news you know that was never out
there and if they don't you know that's
one way to easily weed them out but if
they do know something that was never
published it makes you sort of think oh
well maybe i need to look at this person
further so that's one reason why you do
it but another reason you you also you
keep it secret or you keep you know you
keep it um without leaking is you know
sometimes investigations don't end up in
criminal in in crime being um
charges being brought and you know
a lot of people get investigated for a
lot of things that you've never heard
about and
the minute you start
you start sort of saying oh this person
is being investigated for something and
people hear about it that can leave a
stain on a perfectly innocent person's
life forever it literally will follow
them forever and look i'm less concerned
about that with donald trump but in
general in general that is why you
really don't it's not right it's it's
not right that it that that you know um
that that happens and the other thing
too is you know you don't want your car
your case tried in the court of public
opinion you want your your case tried
based on evidence and and when it is
tried in the court of public opinion you
got all these commentators now you got
everyone including me have a podcast and
you know we sit here and we comment on
everything under the sun
you know it it's we don't know the facts
we don't know the evidence we don't know
any of it and so here we're you know
we're we're potentially infecting a jury
pool you know that's going to sit and
hear the case because sometimes you know
when you when you have too much
commentary and peanut gallery that don't
don't know all the facts you know cases
take on a feeling and and and again
there's the presumption of innocence and
we still have to prove our cases beyond
a reasonable doubt to a jury and you
don't want them coming in with a
preconceived notion or a bias or or they
can't sit and be fair because they've
heard too much about it so there's lots
of reasons i'm sure i'm forgetting half
of them you know why
why it's important to um you know to
keep things
you know very much um not just quiet but
like you try your case in court you know
prosecutors shouldn't talk about cases
outside of court you talk about it in
court and and that's where it should
happen that's where the words should
happen and that's where the information
should happen and i i feel very strongly
about that
so that that's a that's those are all
really good points and the point that of
that you don't want stuff to leak out
you don't want stuff to be political and
you don't want a lot of commentary this
is why i've been saying for a long time
that this is the reason why republicans
mitch mcconnell kevin mccarthy did and
donald trump himself did not want a 9 11
style commission uh to investigate the
january 6
attack on the capital the insurrection
and the reason why they want it
political they want it out in the open
they wanted uh democrats to have a
political
investigation which the the
investigation with the january 6th
select committee is political it's a
political body it's politicians and
they're investigating it it is a
political investigation and we heard we
heard some noise that possibly the
january 6 select committee was not going
to be making criminal referrals possibly
for some high crimes they're just making
referrals that have to do with their
committee being the contempt charges
like yesterday
we seen that dan scavino and peter
navarro were
advanced they are going to refer
congress is going to refer
those two individuals for contempt of
congress because not only
not only are they not
doing the subpoena thing but they are
actively going out into the public
navarro specifically
saying the things that the january 6
select committee wants to question them
on um and then he's claiming executive
privilege so there's a lot of working uh
going on in there
but do you think that is the one reason
why republicans didn't want am i right
that they didn't want a 911 style
commission because they wanted this to
be political for the reasons that you're
saying is to you know pollute pollute an
investigation from the department of
justice or the southern district in new
york or maybe a district in georgia
where there could be possible election
crimes do you think that's why possibly
that the republicans wanted that i think
it is and i think it's a miscalculation
but what do you think
i don't think they're that smart i mean
you're giving them way too much credit i
hate to say it i think they don't want
it because they don't want the facts out
there
i think they they it's so ugly it's so
bad
and until you you know
until you read sort of i i just recently
read a 44-page decision
that judge carter issued in california
regarding john eastman and
and whether or not certain documents are
privileged and in order to make that
that ruling he had to see you know under
an attorney-client privilege and and one
of the exceptions is it's part of the
crime fraud exception and
he and to do that he you have to spell
out was a crime committed and so he
spent many many many many pages
basically creating a roadmap for the
department of justice or anybody else
listening
there was a crime that committed it's
horrific and this is how you prosecute
it and this is how you prosecute the
president and so i i think they don't
want those facts out there and i think
that's why why they're doing doing this
because they're hoping that biden does
sort of what he said he was going to do
which is let's bring us all together and
let's move past it heal the country and
i think they're hoping that the facts
never come out i mean you might be right
i i just i can't imagine that they that
they
aren't doing anything other than
panicking that these that the facts not
come out but you are right it does by
them having this you know i have such
mixed feelings about the house
um
about the house select committee uh
doing this investigation and the reason
i have mixed feelings about it is
number one it does infuse politics into
what's potentially a criminal
prosecution and it only hurts a
prosecution
because now it's going to be viewed as
political and it you want you want any
pr first of all i i'm going to make very
clear i absolutely think there should be
a prosecution i'm hoping there should be
a prosecution and i want there to be a
prosecution and i want there to be not
just a prosecution but a conviction
and a successful prosecution so for that
to happen
the worst thing you can do is infect it
with politics it's the thing that will
make every person every potential juror
and every everybody think it's
illegitimate and it's a witch hunt and
you're going to feed into what donald
trump is going to say if he is
prosecuted that it's political because
it came from the house so i'm hoping to
god the house does not make a
quote-unquote referral because
making a referral is not a thing you
don't need it
right like people department of justice
has it right so that's right
can i tell you prosecutors will read
something in a newspaper and say oh wow
that's investigative journalism i'm
going to now issue subpoenas and look
into that myself that that's you know
you don't need much to bring a case you
literally
you you could have a witness tell you
about it you could have a police officer
tell you about it or you can read about
it in the newspaper wait a second you're
telling me you're telling me you could
have watched the january 6 insurrection
on tv and you could bring you could
bring uh that case to a grand jury based
on the evidence that's just out there in
the open is that what you're saying is
that you can start an investigation that
way start an investigation that way yes
oh okay okay so um you don't need a
referral so don't do it because then you
infuse politics into it so i'm hoping to
god they don't do it the other thing
that i the reason i say i have mixed
feelings about the january 6 committee
is take a step back for a minute every
single person on that committee is also
one of the victims of the crime right
many of them were there that day many of
them were attacked were terrified for
their life imagine any other crime any
other case where the jury
you pick for the jury people who are
actually victims of the crime i think
think about a rape case and the the you
know the rape victim is going to be the
person sitting on the jury and and and
listening you know to the evidence i
mean
they can't be objective you just can't
it makes no sense whatsoever that
they're doing this if you want a
prosecution if there's not going to be a
prosecution and they want to get the
facts out there and issue a report and
hold hearings and and whatever then i
get it then you have a hearing and
that's why the 911 commission was was so
appropriate because most of the people
who did that died and you know they they
they died in in the plane crash et
cetera so you know there you couldn't
bring a lot of those prosecutions if any
so the people the public wanted to know
what happened how did it happen
and how did we get to that point and it
made all the sense in the world that you
would have a 911 commission but we are
hoping for a prosecution here and so i
would say to to congress back off you
know
just really just the whole thing about
the referral you know um
i know that that navarro and scavino
there was a referral
because of this being held in contempt
and that is really the only thing that
they should make referrals about are
people who they want to be held in
contempt of congress and that's
appropriate because
because that's something that's
happening in congress you know don't
forget there's there's three branches of
government right you know and separation
of powers you've got you know the the
president's the executive branch um
you've got the judicial branch which is
the judges and you've got congress which
is the legislative branch and and and
the department of justice um
interestingly falls under the executive
branch under the president not under the
judicial branch even though it's you
know it's it's um even though it's it's
part of the same system you know the
court system and so so you know by the
by if you
by not doing what congress wants you to
do the congress is actually the victim
of contempt of congress and so they're
the ones then you know referring or
reporting what happened to the executive
branch and to the justice department who
are the only ones who can actually bring
an indictment and prosecute that and so
you know so that is an appropriate
referral but but the january 6
insurrection that you don't need a
referral it was on tv they know about it
investigate it and if there should be a
crime brought then bring it and if
honest and also if there shouldn't be a
crime brought if someone did not commit
a crime then don't bring it and we
should all live with that and know that
it wasn't about politics that it was
about
looking at the facts and doing an
investigation and seeing where the facts
lead and if a crime occurred and you can
prove it beyond a reasonable doubt bring
the case i think you can prove it beyond
a reasonable doubt um
and and you know i i i don't understand
why um
if they don't bring the case but but
that's that's where we are with this
well you know i think the department of
justice uh has has a case um and they've
shown by the many prosecutions that
they've i mean there are people with
their uh cold bare feet on a prison
floor right now um from the for the
january six insurance they've made over
700 arrests right and the other the
other thing that is significant that i
think is evidence that the department of
justice is going to sniff out any crimes
and prosecute and indict anyone uh
rather you know about it or not uh you
being the public um that
the oath keepers had no clue those 11
people had no clue that they were gonna
be indicted the day that they were
indicted uh enrique tario the the leader
of the proud boys no clue that he was
gonna be indicted so much so that the
guy was almost naked when he was
arrested so this idea that we ha we have
to know what merit garland department of
justice is doing
to make sure that they're held
accountable is kind of ridiculous the
other thing too that i just want to add
is that merrick garland isn't actually
in charge of prosecuting in people in
the jurisdiction of dc he is the
attorney general but he is not the
prosecutor in dc i think a lot of people
get that confused and maybe maybe i'm
wrong to point that out but i actually
think that is a significant thing that
merrick garland actually has as the
attorney general he is the tippy top of
the department of justice and there is a
lot of other cases that are going on
other than just the cases that have to
do with january 6. so inside the
jurisdiction of dc which is very busy
i've heard they've tried to hire uh
several hundred more attorneys to try to
try these cases uh to get them through
the system because there is so many
cases that are being brought
and it's
it it's kind of just the irony is like
oh they're not doing anything but
they're hiring like hundreds of
attorneys to get these cases through the
court system but merrick garland isn't
the actual prosecutor in the dc
jurisdiction he is
the boss of the person who would
prosecute those cases is that correct
that is correct every jurisdiction has
its own united states attorney appointed
by the president confirmed by the senate
and merrick garland is the boss
right so he doesn't actually bring those
cases speaking of dc this case
of the secret service
this morning that is kind of like
blowing up on twitter and these videos
of this i want to play real quick here
let me see if i can play this video can
you you can see this here this is a
video of a couple fbi agents
i was trying to sound off walking out of
a building called crossing
um and i guess it's a luxury apartment
building in dc
but apparently what has happened is that
there was uh several
i i guess they were uh phony dhs agents
is what they were posing as
and i i don't know if i guess they were
renting apartments for secret service
agents that possibly could have
um been protecting the first lady i i'm
not sure what what do you know about
this story so far
this so this is just a crazy
banana story that i've i think we don't
know enough because
either these are real
secret you know i asked some people in
law enforcement this morning because i
was like this can't possibly be true and
and i think
there's a possibility that they might
actually be
um
they might actually be agents of some
sort so let's i think we have because if
they're not this is a really really
dangerous story so there's two
individuals
um
who were posing as federal agents
and it depends on who you ask what
agents they were posing as some super
secret something or other they were
living in an apartment building where
many
fbi agents secret service agents and dhs
agents live in washington
and they seem to have a lot of money and
so they're being funded you know by
renting these expensive apartments and
um and having access to things that i
don't know who's funding them so at
first i was like this is either a
foreign government or a terrorist group
or
it could you know be both and be the
republican party frankly which you know
right right domestic terrorist domestic
terrorist exactly exactly i mean and
that's what i mean you know um and you
know look
there are there are there are parts of
my
my leanings that have always been both
liberal and conservative and i you know
used to very much um before trump you
know
not be so anti-republican party but
what's happening now
and and many of the people in as ben
myself calls it the gqp and the q anon
you know branch of the republican party
i think there is a domestic terrorism
element too
uh to that anyway these these guys
had access to
uniforms
to badges to guns
to
identifications to cars with lights to
all the bells and whistles to all the
secret equipment to all the things that
if you were law enforcement you would
have access to i mean a lot you know
you you watch tv you see people posing
as law enforcement they might have
bought a badge a fake badge off of you
know
off of the internet somewhere or they
might get a uniform off the internet
somewhere
to have all of the things that these
individuals had is sort of staggering to
have the resources they had to rent the
apartments and um to you know keep up
this charade that they were actual
federal agents the fact that they were
so convincing that they could get close
to the secret service agents that were
guarding the first lady of the united
states that's what blows my mind like
that's the part like holy sh because
really it points out more than um the
question of who these people are is like
what is the seek like there's been so
many dings in the secret service's
reputation over really the last couple
decades um we seen when obama was
president there was several jumped in
they went into the white house i mean
there's just been time after time after
time where the secret service has really
damaged their reputation but that is
probably one of like
people guarding the first lady are
compromised here by these
by who knows who right and that's
probably the most the craziest part
about the story that they were
convincing secret service agents don't
you think at this point i actually
that's why i'm stunned by the story
that's why i think there's a possibility
that maybe they actually are agents
because i i can't believe it otherwise
otherwise where did they get all of this
how did they do it how did they know the
language that you speak you know the
terms that you use the training kind of
you know things that you needed how do
they have access to
all of the law enforcement memorabilia
and bells and whistles and you know
identifications and and tools and toys
and things that they have how did they
have all of that how did they have the
money to rent i think it was like forty
thousand dollars yeah it's like seven
thousand dollars a month for because
this is not like um like a cheap
apartment building this is a luxury
apartment building
and there were two and there were two of
them there were two of them right well
here are two
let me show you a video here this is a
report of i guess a neighbor it doesn't
show his name or his face but he talks a
little bit here um about the the
suspects the the supposed phony dhs
agents the two individuals charged today
um they were they were pretty cool you
know um
they they told us they were special
police so we thought they were actually
police officers walking through the
building with weapons and everything
what did you think when you saw that
they were in person
as federal agents
well i didn't we didn't know
so there's there's a resident he goes on
to say in this um his little interview
here he goes on to say that he he would
they would sit by the pool and hang out
and that's that's kind of how they got
to know him i guess is that these people
did not have any so they didn't have any
suspicion now there is another interview
of a resident that was very leery of
these two gentlemen um and and they go
on to say i guess that kind of creeped
the women out or something in the
building you know i'm not sure if there
was like an
incident or something but there there
apparently is a couple different views
of the residents in the building of who
these people were
but it just
uh because i hear what you're saying
about
maybe these are really agents but
they're not acting in their official
capacity could that be what's going on
is they are agents of the government
somewhere because we've seen during the
january 6 uh i call it the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup um
where
the law enforcement officers uh former
officers former military and were part
of the insurrection they were part of
trying to overthrow the government of
the united states do you think maybe
that's what's going on here is that
they're actually agents they're just not
acting in their capacity they're acting
against their oath
or their former agents and that's how
they have access to
all of the memorabilia the language the
you know they know how to talk you know
there's there's certain sort of
things that you would say and do and and
places that you've been and trainings
that you've had and you know ways to
kind of bond and
and and
get credibility and legitimacy with
other agents to convince them that you
are who you are so maybe they're
formerly you know former agents but i
still think there's more there is more
to this story and i don't know what it
is you know is it gonna turn out that
it's being funded by you know by
somebody who who was motivated by
getting close to biden and you know the
first lady was it being motivated by you
know some sort of domestic terrorism or
a foreign government you know like like
the russians you know is it or is it or
is it going to turn out that you know
maybe i watch too much television but
maybe this is all part of some undercut
you know maybe they're so deep
undercover that they were getting blown
and they had to go through with the
undercut you know they had to continue
the the ruse and arrest them and it
sounds like a really good movie this
sounds like a really good movie by the
way there's something is going to come
out there's more to the story because
there is just no way that two guys you
know decided that i'm going to be this
and and be as successful as they are
because the secret service they do a
really really good job yes they've had a
few
um a few things as you point out that
have called it into question but you
know they a lot of i don't think you
know
most presidents don't die or don't get
shot at and
they do a really good job at protecting
them and they do a lot of other things
too other than just um
protect you know that's one of the
things they do is protect you know the
president and and the family and former
presidents which you know they do they
do have a whole other um aspect to them
that investigates financial crimes and
cyber crimes and you know they're it's
an excellent organization and and i you
know so
i don't know i don't know how it
happened and i know that they're going
to do a deep investigation into both who
these guys are but also how it happened
and and we'll see from there but i i
just this is a story to watch for sure
well as this develops we'll we'll have
you back on as we get more news and i
really appreciate you joining us before
before we head out here um we're going
to head into the second hour here we
appreciate karen coming and joining us
today to talk about these topics tell us
where we can find you tell us about
about the the wednesday edition of legal
af right before you go so everyone knows
where to find it where to find you and
how to how to follow you on twitter is
is an important thing here thank you so
yeah so i go by kfa legal i was i was so
impressed you were able to
pronounce my name by the way so oh yeah
yeah yeah cause it's not easy
practice i practice yeah so i figured
you know a lot of people in my old job
called me kfa because it's just so much
easier so i just kept it and so kfa
legals who i am on twitter and i'm a
co-host of legal af wednesday edition
you can um you know catch us through
youtube through twitter through midas
touch you know wherever you get your
podcast but you know follow the minus
touch and you know they're they're
amazing the midas touch.com and the
midas mighty as you gave them a shout
out or they're really the fuel that
keeps us all going because they're just
so loyal and wonderful and
you know it makes it all worth it so
thank you so much for having me well
shout out to the midas mighty and um i'm
going to i'm going to let pope because
i've had pope back on pop kind of
invented the pope popping yeah but um i
i i have po poc on i'm gonna you know
i'm gonna have to text him and tell him
hey popock you know you're a great guest
but this kfa oh my gosh
she she may just take your seat at the
table here for the the tony michael's
podcast uh legal af correspondent i
guess we could call it that maybe i
appreciate it you know but i need a
catchy freight like the po pop pocket or
whatever it's called poke poc
it's a catchy phrase yeah i know what
watch this watch
so there's there's the the sound that we
do when popeye comes on but you know but
maybe we'll come up with a graphic and
some kind of catchy yeah exactly i think
he's great he's great he's a great he is
he he is he he's a great co-host he's a
great guest uh we always everyone always
loves to have public on it and go
subscribe to the youtube channel you can
go watch all the po poc poppins if you
want over there on our youtube channel
go to the tony michaels podcast on
youtube and you'll find them there thank
you very much for joining us for having
please come back when this secret
service story develops the d.a story
develops that's great we'll have you
back as this develops everyone stick
around we'll be right back after these
messages thank you karen take care